alors là on est en mai 2007 et puis en
2008 vous quittez l'OM vous quittez la
cité phocéenne après quatre saisons 166
matchs 12 buts vous êtes malade vous
chopez une méningite
vous manquez de mourir et là c'est une
saison compliquée pour vous parce que
vous découvrez une forme de sournoiserie
d'hypocrisie on vous tourne le dos ouais
c'est ce qui
c'est ce qui a c'est ce qui m'a façonné
aussi en tant qu'homme et en tant que
que joueur et que j'ai appris plus ou
moins qu'en fait
dans ce milieu là c'est
on a plus des copains de travail que des
véritables amis et
[Musique]
et à quel point
tout allait très vite
quatre mois auparavant
j'étais le chouchou de la France entière
j'étais pas sûr décisif pour l'équipe de
France j'ai marqué mon premier but en
sélection et je reviens j'ai une
méningite et c'est pour ça qu'il y a
deux personnes qui m'ont marqué et que
j'oublierai jamais c'est pas biou
et lui acariens le boxer oui xboxer mais
boxeur bien sûr champion qui était au
conseil de surveillance de
l'Olympique de Marseille sous la demande
de Robert Louis-Dreyfus et qui m'a
envoyé des fleurs chaque jour à
l'hôpital qui ont appelé mes parents
pour prendre de mes nouvelles à chaque
fois parce que malheureusement j'étais
pas sur mon j'étais pas sur mon
téléphone et
et ça je l'ai jamais oublié mais ça m'a
forgé ça m'a forgé ça m'a permis aussi
de
de changer de mettre une carapace aussi
c'est pour ça que toutes ces années je
suis pas resté froid arrogant mais c'est
simplement que je voulais pas m'ouvrir
aux gens pour pas être déçu après